es Día de desalojo en el histórico
monasterio de las cuevas de kiev Hace
unos días los muebles y las cajas fueron
empacados en furgonetas poco antes del
plazo que el gobierno dio hasta este
miércoles para que cientos de sus
habitantes abandonaran el lugar las
autoridades sospechan que algunos de los
que viven en el complejo apoyan en
secreto a Moscú en su guerra contra
Ucrania una acusación fuertemente negada
por el líder del monasterio que quiere
Que todos se queden donde están
nosotros como creyentes y como monjes
permaneceremos en el labra mientras sea
físicamente posible
la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana se separó
del patriarcado de Moscú en 2019 y cortó
definitivamente sus lazos el año pasado
por el apoyo de este último a la guerra
de Rusia contra Ucrania alrededor del 4%
de los fieles ortodoxos en Ucrania Aún
se identifican con la iglesia rusa cuyo
líder quiril ha respaldado firmemente la
invasión los monjes tienen que pagar el
alquiler del complejo Que es del estado
técnicamente hablando se le saca por
incumplir el contrato de alquiler pero
el asunto se ha vuelto muy político en
noviembre la policía hizo una redada en
el monasterio alegando sospechas de que
albergaba grupos de Sabotaje ciudadanos
extranjeros y armas el ministro de
cultura ucraniano dice que si alguien
quiere quedarse tendrá que jurar lealtad
a la iglesia ortodoxa de Ucrania
hemos pedido a los representantes de la
rama moscovita de la iglesia que se
marchen no se refiere necesariamente a
los monjes los monjes tienen el derecho
y la posibilidad de decidir a qué
iglesia pertenecen
a pesar del plazo de este miércoles el
ministro afirmó que no se expulsaría por
la fuerza a ningún monje del lugar que
es patrimonio Mundial de la UNESCO